بقاض واحد ودون محلفين يمثل امام محكمه
مدنيه في نيويورك الرئيس الامريكي السابق
دونالد ترامب القضيه مدنيه هذه المره
ويتهم فيها ترامب بالاحتيال والتضليل بشان
ثروته فما القصه المدعيه العامه في
نيويورك ليتيسيا جيمز اتهمت ترامب
باستخدام بيانات مضلله بين عامي 201 و
2021 لتضخيم قيمه اصول مجموعته التي تضم
شركات متنوعه تشمل عقارات وفنادق ونوادي
جولف وغيرها خلال تحقيق استمر ثلاث سنوات
وجدت المدعيه العامه ان ترامب وولديه
ايريك ودونالد جونيور بالغوا في قيمه 23
من الاصول الماليه والعقاريه لمجموعته
للحصول على قروض بشروط افضل وفق القاضي
ارثر انرون الذي سينظر في القضيه يتهم
ترامب وولداه بتضخيم قيمه اصولهم بما بين
812 مليون الى اكثر من ملياري دولار بين
و221 امر القاضي انرون بسحب تراخيص اعمال
تجاريه في نيويورك من ترامب ونجليه اضافه
الى مصادره الشركات المستهدفه في القضيه
كما تسعى المدعيه جيمز لتغريم الرئيس
السابق 250 مليون دولار على الاقل وفرض
حظر دائم عليه وعلى نجليه يمنعهم من اداره
اعمالهم في نيويورك وحظر لخمس سنوات على
الانشطه التجاريه والعقاريه لترامب
ومجموعته تضم المجموعه 500 كيان للاعمال
والاستثمار من ابرزها برج ترامب الذي
سيدخل في القضيه حيث يشتبه وفق الادعاء ان
الرئيس الامريكي السابقه بالغ في قيمته من
200 الى 300 مليون
دولار